RedHat OpenShift is the enterprise
kubernetes platform and with the latest
version open chef for the platform has
undergone significant improvements to
developer experience automation and the
management of the platform itself but
what exactly changed and what do you
need to know about open chef for let's
get started
so open shift is kubernetes at the core
and with open chef for the platform is
now driven by operators yes this
includes the services the support
openshift as well as app services that
are deployed by users like you this is
significant so we'll start with covering
operators next we'll jump into one of
the first things users will notice in
open ship for that is an improved
developer experience and this comes with
significant updates to the console and
then finally we'll dive into some of the
community driven projects that open ship
is adopted into supported solutions
things like open ships service mesh and
open shift pipelines there's actually
more but we'll touch on these two today
starting with operators essentially they
allow you to automate the life cycle of
containers let's say I'm deploying a
simple front-end and back-end
application once I deploy all of them
into my cluster I've got to manage all
of the automation around the config of
individual applications but with an
operator I can take a different approach
by installing an operator into a cluster
with OLM or operator lifecycle manager I
can enable new C RDS or custom resource
definitions these C RDS allow me to
manage my application using custom
config files tailored for my application
in addition any automation that I need
can be built into the operator itself
essentially I've extended the kubernetes
api to create new custom resources that
are tailored to the resources that you
regularly work with in openshift for the
services that make up openshift itself
are actually managed by operators this
means we get to take advantage of that
same framework to easily do installation
and upgrades of OpenShift itself check
out the operator SDK to create your own
operators or use the embedded operator
hub and OpenShift to start with quickly
and with existing
next let's talk about one of the first
things you'll notice in the platform and
that is an improved developer experience
starting from the console
the main thing you'll notice is a
different view for administrators and
developers there's new dashboard
capabilities for streamlined deployment
of applications whether you start with a
git repo container image or deployment
Hammel in addition you'll get better
observability into the platform for
example there's an events view which
tracks everything happening in your
cluster there's improved administration
of the cluster itself with a new user
manage section as well lastly let's
close with some of the community driven
projects that OpenShift is supporting
one of them is going to be open shift
pipelines with Tecton tech tongs is a
cloud native way to declare CI CD
pipelines and is based entirely on
kubernetes it starts with defining the
tasks that make up a CI CD flow which
actually run as pods in your cluster
these make up a pipeline and that's able
to deploy applications into your cluster
in OpenShift there's actually UI
integration between Tecton and OpenShift
so OpenShift pipelines lets you manage
your CI CD all in the dashboard the
other community-driven project I want to
talk about is open shipped service mesh
this is based on sto imagine you have a
number of services that are dependent on
one another a number of concerns arise
in the interaction between these
services how do you actually manage
these interdependent complexities
well instead of managing them in the app
itself you can take advantage of the sto
control plant which uses sidecars to
basically help you control how these
micro services connect with each other
how do they enforce policies and then
even observe how they behave that way
the capabilities rest on the control
plane rather than the apps themselves
thanks for joining me for this quick
video or reviewing some of the newest
features in openshift 4 as always if you
liked the video or you have any comments
please drop a like or a comment below be
sure to subscribe and stay tuned for
more videos like this in the future